- The U.S. government
is expected to borrow
$2 trillion a year for the next decade.
That's huge and unprecedented.
Investors are starting to think
that all this borrowing
could have some major impacts
on stocks, bonds, and all
kinds of other investments.
I'm going to explain why
the government is borrowing
so much money, why all that
borrowing will impact markets,
and what this could mean
for the investing world
in the near future.
Let's get into it.
The U.S. national debt
recently hit $33 trillion,
and the Congressional
Budget Office estimates
our debt could surpass $40
trillion in five years.
That's because even though the
government isn't rolling out
any big new stimulus programs,
it is bringing in a lot less revenue
than it did over the past two years.
Revenue is basically shorthand for taxes.
The government is collecting less taxes
because people are
collecting less capital gains
on the sale of things like
stocks, businesses, and houses.
Remember, you pay taxes
in the year following taxable events.
So the taxes from big stock
and housing market gains
we saw in 2021 were largely
recorded in fiscal year 2022.
The government is also
paying a lot more in interest
so it can borrow money
to pay for the deficit.
The interest rate on
two-year government bonds
at the beginning of 2022 was less than 1%.
Now that rate is over 5%.
When you're paying interest on billions
or trillions of dollars in
debt, that difference adds up.
Jefferies U.S. economist Thomas Simons
is expecting the government to
issue just under $4 trillion
in medium and long-term
debt in fiscal year 2024,
and it's going to have to sell
that debt at the same time
that some of the largest
buyers are cutting back.
The Federal Reserve is the
largest holder of treasury bonds,
but the U.S. Central Bank is projected
to reduce its holdings
by up to $60 billion per
month moving forward.
And the latest report from
the Treasury Department
shows China cut its holdings
of U.S. government bonds
to the lowest level since May 2009.
China was the largest foreign
holder of U.S. government debt
as recently as 2019
and held more than $1 trillion
in treasuries in early 2021.
But the country has reduced its holdings
by almost $300 billion since then.
When there's more supply and less demand,
that usually means that prices fall.
For bonds, it also means that yields rise.
Treasury yields reached
their highest level
in more than 15 years in September,
and the mountain of new debt that's coming
could push them even higher.
Higher yields historically
increase the value of the dollar
and boost the attractiveness
of safe assets
like money market funds.
Retail traders and
professional money managers
have pushed a record amount of
cash into money market funds
which are paying the highest
interest rates in decades.
Higher yields also have made investments
in risky assets like
stocks less attractive.
The thinking goes that if you
can get a guaranteed 5% return
on an asset that's a lot
like a savings account,
why take the risk on stocks?
And because most public
companies have to borrow money
by issuing bonds, their costs will go up,
which often makes them less profitable.
This is especially true for
so-called growth stocks.
These are usually tech companies
that have very high market valuations,
even though they don't
make a lot of profit.
Tech has made up an
increasingly large share
of the benchmark S&P 500 stock index
and is the backbone of the Nasdaq.
With the outlook for
the economy uncertain,
you could see more investors
start to favor parking their
money with the U.S. government
or leaving it in money market funds.
(gentle music)